nos piden comparar estos dos números
esta es una imagen de la sección de
ejercicios de khan academy así que no
puedo hacer clic aquí pero aún así vamos
a resolver el ejercicio y elegir alguno
de estos tres vamos a comparar dos
puntos siete con dos enteros 17 sobre
100 y lo vamos a escribir hay muchas
formas de resolver esto por ejemplo
convertir ambas cifras en números mixtos
2.7 es lo mismo que dos enteros y siete
décimos y esto lo podemos comparar con
esto de aquí que es dos enteros con
diecisiete centésimos
ambos tienen un 2 así que vamos a
comparar las fracciones que es más
grande 7 decimos o 17 centésimos pueden
convertir esto en centésimos
multiplicando el denominador por 10 que
convierte el 10 al 100 y también tenemos
que multiplicar el numerador por 10 que
nos convierte el 7 en 70
así que 2.7 es igual a 2 enteros y 70
centésimos y 70 centésimos sin duda es
mayor que 10 y 7 centésimos
así que 2.7 o 2 enteros 7 décimos o dos
enteros 70 centésimos va a ser mayor que
este otro número abrimos el símbolo
hacia el lado del número más grande otra
forma en la que pudimos resolver esto es
convertir a ambas cantidades a decimales
tenemos 2.7 que podemos dejar como
decimal y el 2 con 17 sobre 100 lo
podemos escribir como 2.17 y hay varias
formas en las que podemos hacer esta
comparación una de ellas es decir que
2.7 o 2 con 7 décimas es lo mismo que 2
con 70 centésimas aquí tengo 70
centésimas y acá 17 centésimas por lo
que el primero será más grande u otra
forma de resolverlo es fijándonos en las
posiciones de mayor valor ambos tienen
dos unidades lo que no nos dice mucho
pero cuando llegamos a las décimas
notamos que este número tiene un 77
décimas y el otro sólo tiene una décima
por lo que este número es mayor que este
otro hagamos otro problema cuál de las
siguientes es menor que 2.0 3
una forma de resolverlo es convertir
todas estas cantidades como decimales
aquí tenemos un entero otro entero y
aquí no tengo un entero completo tomé un
entero y lo divide en décimos y resalte
dos décimos así que esto de aquí es
igual a dos enteros
con dos décimos aquí están los dos
enteros y las dos secciones iguales y
que es lo mismo que 2.2
si queremos compararlo con dos puntos 0
3 hay muchas formas de hacerlo una de
ellas es ponerla como 2.20 20 centésimos
por lo que 2 con 20 centésimos sin duda
es mayor que 2 con 3 centésimos esto no
es menor que dos puntos 0 3
otra forma de resolverlo es tomar el 2
con 2 decimos que es igual a 2 con 20
centésimos que es otra forma de
representar dos puntos 20 y tomar el
número con lo que lo comparamos
expresando lo como 2 con 3 centésimos
porque 20 centésimos es mayor que 3
centésimos la siguiente opción es dos
enteros con 12 centésimas lo cual es
interesante porque ya tenemos nuestra
cantidad original representada como 2 y
3 centésimos la parte entera es igual
en ambos números pero si nos fijamos en
las fracciones 12 centésimas es mayor
que 3 centésimos por lo que este tampoco
es mayor que 2.0 3 y que hay con 23
centésimas lo podemos expresar como 23
sobre 100 o 0.23
se sientan tentados a decir que 23
centésimos es mayor que 3 centésimos
pero recuerden que tenemos 2 enteros
aquí y aquí abajo no tenemos ningún
entero como ven aquí no hay enteros y
aquí arriba tenemos 2 enteros por lo que
aquí abajo no importa cuánto centésimos
tengamos esto es menor que 2.0 atrás la
única de las tres opciones que cumple
con la condición hagamos otro problema
más ordena los siguientes valores de
menor a mayor
nuevamente les comento que esta es una
imagen de la sección de ejercicios y no
puedo interactuar con las cantidades de
la misma forma que lo harían ustedes en
esta página de ejercicios del portal
así que analizaremos los números primero
y después los escribiremos en orden
vamos a expresarlos como decimales pues
creo que es la forma más fácil la
primera ya está en decimales 2.59 la
segunda 24 décimas es lo mismo que tener
24 sobre 10
y esto es lo mismo que tener 20 sobre 10
+ 4 sobre 10 20 sobre 10 estos son dos
enteros así que esto es dos enteros y
cuatro décimos o también 2.4 si
comparamos esto con 2.59 y aquí
permítanme escribir un cero podemos
verlo como 2 y 40 centésimas todas estas
son diferentes maneras de representar
esto y ahora algunos de ustedes podrían
decir que 10 décimas son un entero 20
décimas son dos enteros por lo que 24
décimas son dos enteros con cuatro
décimos o 2.4 o 2.40 ahora veamos este
otro número dos con tres décimas lo
podemos expresar como 2.3 y si queremos
verlo en términos de centésimos podemos
decir que esto es igual a 2 con 30 sobre
100 que podemos representar como 2.30 y
la razón por la que dejo esto como
centésimos es para
facilitar esta comparación comparamos
2.59 con 2.40 y ahora con 2.30 todos
tienen dos en el lugar de las unidades
por lo que ahora revisamos el lugar de
las décimas y vemos que esta es la que
tiene más décimas cinco décimas esta
otra es la siguiente con más décimas y
esta es la que tiene menos cantidad de
décimas sólo tres ordenando de menor a
mayor tenemos dos con tres decimos que
es igual a 2.3 y las siguientes 24
décimos o décimas que es igual a 2.4 y
la más grande es 2.59 nuevamente todos
tienen dos en el lugar de las unidades y
estas son tres décimas cuatro décimas y
cinco décimas